En 1962, Charles Van Doren, qui devint par la suite rédacteur en chef de l'Enclycopédie Britannica,
disait que l'encyclopédie idéale devait être radicale -- elle ne devait plus être sûre.
Mais si vous connaissez l'histoire de Britannica depuis 1962,
l'encyclopédie était tout sauf radicale :
toujours extrêmement sûre et indigeste.
Wikipédia, à côté de ça, a commencé avec une idée radicale,
celle que nous imaginons tous un monde
où chaque personne sur la planète
ait un accès libre à l'ensemble de la connaissance humaine.
Et c'est ce que nous faisons. Donc Wikipédia --
vous en avez vu une petite démonstration --
est une encyclopédie sous licence libre. Elle est écrite par des milliers de volontaires
de toute la planète dans beaucoup, beaucoup de langues.
Elle est écrite en utilisant le logiciel Wiki --
qui est le type de logiciel qu'il a présenté --
-- qui permet à n'importe qui d'éditer et de sauvegarder rapidement,
et devient immédiatement disponible en ligne.
Tout ce qui touche à Wikipédia est dirigé par une équipe virtuelle composée uniquement de volontaires.
Donc quand Yochai parle de nouvelles méthodes d'organisation,
il décrit exactement Wikipédia. Et ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui
c'est vous parler un peu plus de son fonctionnement interne.
Wikipédia appartient à la Fondation Wikimédia, que j'ai fondée,
une organisation à but non-lucratif. Et la visée, le principe fondateur de la Fondation Wikimédia,
est de donner l'accès à une encyclopédie libre à chaque personne sur la planète.
Et donc si vous réfléchissez à ce que cela implique,
cela veut dire beaucoup plus que construire un site web cool.
Nous sommes vraiment intéressés à tous les problèmes d'accès à internet, la pauvreté mondiale,
pour permettre aux gens vivant n'importe où d'avoir l'information dont ils ont besoin
afin de prendre de bonnes décisions.
Nous allons avoir à faire à énormément de travail qui ne se limite pas à la toile.
C'est une des raisons principales qui nous a poussé à choisir un modèle de licence libre,
parce que cela permet aux entrepreneurs locaux --
ou à n'importe qui qui le souhaite, de prendre notre contenu
et de faire tout ce qu'il veut avec -- vous pouvez le copier, le redistribuer,
et ceci commercialement ou non.
Il y a donc énormément d'opportunités qui vont apparaître autour de Wikipédia
partout dans le monde.
Nous fonctionnons grâce aux donations du public,
et l'une des choses les plus intéressantes à ce propos
est le peu d'argent nécessaire au fonctionnement de Wikipédia.
Donc Yochai vous a montré le graphique sur les coûts de la presse écrite.
Je vais vous dire quel est le coût de Wikipédia,
mais d'abord je vais vous montrer l'ampleur de Wikipedia.
Donc nous avons environ 600 000 articles en Anglais.
Nous avons deux millions d'articles au total écrits dans de nombreuses langues différentes.
Les langues les plus importantes sont l'Allemand, le Japonais et le Français.
Toutes les langues de l'Europe de l'Ouest sont vraiment importantes.
Mais seulement un tier de tout notre trafic
est pour le Wikipédia en Anglais,
ce qui surprend beaucoup de monde.
Beaucoup de personnes pensent qu'Internet est un média majoritairement anglophone,
mais nous sommes vraiment global. Wikipédia existe dans beaucoup, beaucoup de langues.
Le succès que nous avons connu -- Le site est dans le top 50 des sites web
et nous sommes plus populaires que le New York Times.
Donc c'est là que nous arrivons à la discussion de Yochai.
Ce graphique montre la croissance de Wikipédia -- nous sommes la ligne bleue --
et ici c'est le New York Times.
Et ce qui est intéressant à ce propos c'est que le site du New York Times est énorme,
une énorme société avec -- je ne sais combien de centaines d'employés.
Nous avons exactement un seul employé,
et cet employé est notre développeur logiciel en chef.
Et il est notre employé uniquement depuis Janvier 2005,
soit après la grosse croissance de Wikipédia.
Donc les serveurs sont dirigés par une petite équipe de volontaires,
tous les ajouts sont faits par des volontaires.
Et la façon dont nous sommes organisés
n'est semblable à aucune organisation traditionnelle.
Les gens se demandent, "Mais qui s'occupe de tout ça ?"
ou "Qui fait ça ?". Et la réponse est : n'importe qui qui le souhaite.
C'est quelque chose de très perturbateur et nouveau.
Nous avons environ 90 serveurs répartis sur trois endroits différents.
Ces serveurs sont gérés par des administrateurs systèmes volontaires via Internet.
Je peux me connecter à n'importe quel moment du jour ou de la nuit,
et trouver huit à dix personnes m'atttendre
pour me poser une question ou quoi que ce soit à propos des serveurs.
Vous ne pourriez jamais payer pour ça dans une entreprise.
Vous ne pourriez jamais payer pour avoir une équipe de secours en cas de problème
24 heures par jour et faire ce qu'on fait sur Wikipédia.
Nous avons à peu près 1.4 milliards de pages vues par mois,
c'est vraiment devenu énorme.
Et tout est géré par des volontaires.
Le coût total mensuel pour la bande passante est d'environ 5 000 dollars.
Et c'est notre coût principal.
Nous pourrions fonctionner sans l'employé. En fait, nous --
nous avons engagé Brian parce qu'il travaillait à temps partiel depuis deux ans
et à temps plein sur Wikipédia,
donc nous l'avons engagé pour qu'il puisse avoir une vie et aller au cinéma de temps en temps.
La grande question quand vous avez ce type d'organisation très chaotique est,
pourquoi n'est-ce pas de mauvaise qualité ? Pourquoi le site est-il aussi bien qu'il l'est en ce moment ?
Tout d'abord, à quel point est-il bon ? Le site est assez bon. Il n'est pas parfait,
mais c'est beaucoup, beaucoup mieux que vous auriez pu l'imaginer,
étant donné notre modèle très novateur.
Donc quand vous voyez quelqu'un faire une toute petite édition ridicule sur la page me concernant,
vous pensez, oh, tout cela va forcement dégénérer en quelque chose de très mauvais,
Mais quand nous avons vu les tests de qualité -- et il n'y en a pas eu assez pour l'instant,
j'encourage vraiment les gens à en faire plus,
en comparant Wikipédia aux encyclopédies traditionnelles -- nous gagnons les mains dans les poches.
Une revue allemande a comparé Wikipédia Allemand,
qui est beaucoup, beaucoup plus petite que la version anglaise,
à Microsoft Encarta et à Brockhaus Multimédia,
et nous avons gagné loin haut la main.
Ils ont engagé des experts qui sont venus pour lire les articles et en ont comparé la qualité,
et nous avons été très touchés par ce résultat.
Beaucoup de personnes sont au courant à propos de la controverse Bush-Kerry.
C'est un -- les médias en ont énormément parlé.
Ça a commencé avec un article sur Red Herring.
Les journalistes m'ont appelé et ils -- je veux dire, je dois admettre
qu'ils ont bien orthographié mon nom, mais ils voulaient vraiment relayer
que l'élection Bush-Kerry est si litigieuse,
que cela brise la communauté Wikipédia. Et donc ils m'ont cité disant,
"C'est l'élection la plus problématique de toute l'histoire de Wikipédia".
Ce que j'ai vraiment dit, c'est que ce n'était pas du tout problématique.
Donc il y a un léger malentendu. Les articles ont été publiés assez massivement.
Et c'est vrai que nous avions dû par moment verrouiller quelques articles .
Le Time magazine a récement rapporté que
"des décisions extrêmes ont dû être prises,
et Wales a verrouillé les articles sur Kerry et Bush durant la majorité de l'année 2004".
C'est sorti après que j'ai dit au journaliste que nous avions dû verrouillé --
de temps en temps, un petit peu ici et là.
La vérité est que le genre de controverses sur lesquelles vous pourriez
imaginer qu'il y ait débat au sein de la communauté de Wikipédia
ne sont pas du tout des controverses.
Les articles sur des sujets controversés sont beaucoup publiés,
mais cela ne pose pas beaucoup de problèmes au sein de la communauté.
La raison est que la plupart des personnes comprennent le besoin de neutralité.
La vraie lutte n'est pas vraiment entre la gauche et la droite --
ce que la plupart des personnes imaginent --
mais elle est entre le parti des penseurs et le parti des idiots.
Et aucun des bords politique n'a le monopole sur ces qualités.
La vérité à propos de l'incident Bush-Kerry
est que les articles Bush-Kerry
ont été verrouillés moins d'1% du temps en 2004,
et ce n'était pas parce qu'ils étaient sujets à débats,
c'était à cause de vandalisme fréquent --
ce qui arrive quelques fois même sur un plateau --
quelques fois même des journalistes m'ont dit qu'ils avaient vandalisé Wikipédia
et étaient ébahis que cela ai été corrigé aussi rapidement.
Et j'ai dit -- Vous savez, je dis toujours : " S'il vous plaît, ne faites pas ça, ce n'est pas une bonne chose.."
Comment nous faisons ça ?
Quoi -- comment nous gérons les contrôles de qualité ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait -- Comment ça marche ?
Voici plusieurs éléments,
principalement notre politique sociale et quelques éléments du logiciel.
La chose la plus importante est notre politique sur la neutralité.
C'est quelque chose que j'ai mis au clair dès le début,
comme étant un principe fondamental qui est complétement indiscutable.
C'est un concept de coopération,
donc nous ne parlons pas beaucoup de vérité et d'objectivité.
La raison pour ça est que si on dit que nous allons écrire la vérité sur tel sujet,
cela ne va pas nous aider à écrire l'article,
car je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous sur ce qu'est la vérité.
Nous avons ce terme de neutralité dans notre jargon,
qui a sa propre histoire au sein de la communauté,
qui dit principalement qu'à chaque fois qu'il existe un problème controversé,
Wikipedia ne devrait pas prendre position dans le débat,
Nous devons méticuleusement présenter ce que les parties légitimes ont à dire à ce propos.
Cette politique de neutralité est vraiment importante pour nous,
car cela encourage une communauté très diversifiée
à travailler main dans la main afin de produire quelque chose.
Nous avons une grande diversité de contributeurs, en terme de passés
politiques, religieux ou culturels.
En ayant cette politique de neutralité,
qui est non-négociable depuis le début,
nous nous assurons que les gens peuvent travailler ensemble
et que les articles ne deviennent une simple guerre
entre la gauche et la droite.
Si vous vous engager dans ce type de comportement,
on vous demandera de quitter la communauté.
Donc, la relecture en temps réel :
chacun des petits changements sur le site sont classés dans une page des changements récents.
Donc à partir du moment où on fait un changement, il s'affiche sur cette page.
Cette page des changements récents est aussi diffusé sur des canaux IRC,
qui est un canal de discussion sur internet
auquel les gens peuvent accéder avec de nombreux logiciels différents.
Et les gens peuvent obtenir les flux RSS --
Ils peuvent recevoir des notifications par e-mail de ces changements.
Et les utilisateurs peuvent paramétrer leur propre liste de suivi.
Ma page est donc sur la liste de suivi de quelques volontaires,
parce qu'elle est parfois vandalisée.
Et jusque là, ce qu'il se passe est que quelqu'un va se rendre compte du changement très rapidement,
et ils vont simplement annuler le changement.
Il y a un flux pour les nouvelles pages, par exemple,
vous pouvez aller sur une certaine page de Wikipedia
et voir tous les nouveaux articles quand ils sont créés.
C'est très important, parce qu'un grand nombre des pages qui sont crées
sont justes des torchons qui doivent être supprimés.
Mais c'est aussi l'une des choses les plus intéressantes et amusantes de Wikipedia,
certains des nouveaux articles.
Les gens vont commencer un article sur un sujet intéressant,
d'autres vont trouver ça intriguant
et vont sauter dedans et aider à le rendre bien meilleur.
Nous avons effectivement des publications par des utilisateurs anonymes,
ce qui est l'une des choses les plus controversées et intrigantes à propos de Wikipédia.
Donc Chris a été capable de faire sa modification -- Il n'a pas eu à se connecter ou autre,
il est juste allé sur le site et a fait un changement.
Mais il se trouve que seulement 18 % de toutes les publications du site
sont faîtes par des utilisateurs anonymes.
C'est quelque chose de très important à comprendre,
la vaste majorité des publications qui vont sur le site
proviennent d'une communauté très proche de peut-être 600 à 1000 personnes
qui sont en communication constante.
Et nous avons plus de 40 chaînes IRC, 40 liste d'envoi.
Toutes ces personnes se connaissent. Ils communiquent, nous avons des réunions hors-ligne.
Ce sont les gens qui portent le site sur leurs épaules,
et ils sont, dans un sens, semi-professionnel dans ce qu'ils font,
les standards que nous nous imposons à nous-même sont équivalents ou supérieurs
à des critères de qualité professionnel.
Nous n'arrivons pas toujours à atteindre ces standards
mais c'est ce à quoi nous aspirons.
Cette communauté très rapprochée représente les gens qui s'impliquent vraiment pour le site
et ils font partie des gens les plus intelligent que j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer,
Bien sûr, c'est mon boulot de dire ça, mais c'est pourtant vrai.
Le type de gens qui ont été convaincu d'écrire une encyclopédie pour s'amuser
ont tendance à être des gens très intelligents.
Les outils et le logiciel : il y a de nombreux outils qui nous permettent --
par nous, j'entend la communauté -- d'effectuer un suivi de tout le travail.
Ceci est exemple d'un historique d'une page sur la terre plate,
et vous pouvez voir quelques changements qui ont été faits.
Ce qui est bien avec cette page c'est que vous pouvez immédiatement jeter un oeil à ça
et voir, oh OK, je comprend maintenant.
Quand n'importe qui vient et regarde ça -- il voit que quelqu'un,
une adresse IP anonyme, a fait un changement à ma page --
cela semble douteux -- Qui est cette persone ? N'importe qui qui regarde ça,
peux immédiatement voir en rouge tous les changements qui ont été établis,
pour voir, Ok, bon, ces mots ont changés, des choses comme ça.
Donc c'est l'un des outils que nous pouvons utiliser pour suivre vraiment rapidement l'histoire d'une page.
Une autre chose que nous faisons au sein de la communauté
est que nous considérons tous les articles comme incomplets.
La plupart des règles sociales et des méthodes de travail
sont complètement améliorables dans le logiciel.
Tout ce matériel est juste sur les pages Wiki.
Et il n'y a donc rien dans le logiciel qui enfrunt la loi.
L'exemple que je vous montre ici est une page de vote pour la suppression d'une page.
Donc, je l'ai mentionné plus tôt, les personnes qui "foutent le bordel" --
cela doit être supprimé. Dans les cas comme ça, les administrateurs les détruisent tout simplement.
Il n'y pas de raisons d'avoir une grosse dispute à propos de ça.
Mais vous pouvez imaginer qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres terrains pour lesquels la question se pose,
Le sujet est-il suffisamment pertinent pour aller dans une encyclopédie ?
L'information est-elle vérifiable ? Est-ce une blague ? Est-ce vrai ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Donc nous avions besoin d'une méthode sociale pour trouver des réponses à cela.
Et la méthode qui est née organiquement au sein de la communauté
est la page vote pour suppression.
Et dans cet exemple particulier que nous avons ici, c'est un film,
"Twisted Issues", et la première personne dit,
"Si c'est hypothétiquement un film, il a raté le test Google misérablement."
Le test Google est d'aller voir dans Google pour voir si il y est présent,
car si quelque chose n'est même pas dans Google, il n'existe probablement pas du tout.
Ce n'est pas une règle parfaite, mais c'est un point de départ pour une recherche rapide.
Donc quelqu'un dit : "Supprimez le, s'il vous plaît, supprimez le -- ce n'est pas pertinent."
Puis quelqu'un dit : "Attendez, attendez, je l'ai trouvé.
Je l'ai trouvé dans un livre, Le Guide des films Catastrophes :
les 20 films underground que vous devez avoir vu."
Oh, Ok. Donc la personne suivante dit : "Nettoie-le"
Quelqu'un dit : "je l'ai trouvé sur IMDB. Gardez-le, gardez-le !"
Et ce qui est intéressant à propos de tout ça est que le logiciel --
ces votes sont justes -- ils sont juste tapés dans une page.
Ceci est en fait plus un dialogue qu'un vote.
C'est vrai qu'à la fin de la journée
un administrateur peut jeter un oeil à tout ça et dire,
Ok, 18 suppressions, 2 maintiens, nous allons le supprimer.
Mais dans d'autres cas, cela pourrait être 18 suppressions et 2 maintiens mais nous le garderions quand même,
parce que si ces deux derniers maintiens disent : "Attendez une minute, attendez une minute.
Personne d'autre n'a vu ça mais je l'ai trouvé dans un livre,
et j'ai trouvé un lien vers une page qui le décrit et je vais le corriger demain,
donc merci de ne pas le supprimer," et l'article survivrait.
Ce qui compte aussi c'est qui sont les gens qui votent.
Comme je l'ai dit, c'est une communauté très soudée.
Ici, tout en en bas, : "Gardez, vrai film", Rick Kay.
Rick Kay est un wikipedien très connu
qui fait une énorme quantité de travail avec le vandalisme, les faux
et les votes pour suppression.
Sa voix a beaucoup de poids au sein de la communauté
car il sait ce qu'il fait.
Donc, comment tout cela est-il gouverné ?
Les gens veulent vraiment savoir, Ok, les administrateurs, les choses comme ça.
Donc le modèle de gouvernance de Wikipédia, de gouvernance de la communauté,
est très confus, mais constitue un mélange de consensus qui permettent de travailler.
je veux dire que nous essayons de ne pas voter sur le contenu des articles,
parce que l'avis de la majorité n'est pas nécessairement neutre.
Un peu de démocratie, tous les administrateurs --
ce sont les gens qui ont la possibilité de supprimer des pages,
cela ne signifie pas qu'ils ont le droit de supprimer des pages,
ils doivent quand même suivre les règles -- mais ils sont élus,
ils sont élus par la communauté. Parfois les gens --
des trolls quelconques sur Internet -- aiment m'accuser de soudoyer les administrateurs
pour biaiser le contenu de l'encyclopédie.
Je rigole souvent de tout ça, car je n'ai en fait aucune idée de comment ils sont élus.
Il y a une petite quantité d'aristocracie.
vous en avez eu un apercu quand j'ai parlé par exemple
de la voix de Rick Kay qui a plus de portée que celle de quelqu'un que nous ne connaissons pas.
Je donne ce discours parfois avec Angela, qui vient juste d'être réélue
au conseil de la communauté -- au conseil de la Fondation,
avec près de plus de deux fois le score de l'autre candidat.
Et je l'embarrasse toujours car je dis, bon, Angela
pourrait toujours s'en sortir en ne faisant absolument rien pour Wikipedia,
car elle est très admirée et très puissante.
Mais l'ironie est que, bien sûr, Angela peut faire cela car elle est la personne élue
dont vous savez qu'elle n'enfreindrait jamais aucune règle de Wikipedia.
J'aime aussi dire que c'est la seule personne
qui connaît toutes les règles de Wikipedia, donc...
et après il y a la monarchie et c'est mon rôle dans la communauté, donc...
J'avais décrit ça à Berlin une fois et le lendemain dans les journaux
la presse titrait : "Je suis la Reine d'Angleterre."
Ce n'est pas exactement ce que j'avais dit mais --
la question est mon rôle dans la communauté --
dans le monde du logiciel libre, il y a une longue --
Il existait une vielle tradition du modèle du dictateur bénévole.
donc si vous regardez la plupart des projets de logiciels libres,
ils ont une seule personne en place
dont tout le monde est d'accord pour dire qu'elle est le dictateur bénévole.
Bon, je n'aime pas ce terme de dictateur bénévole,
et je ne pense pas que mon job ou mon rôle dans le monde des idées
est d'être le décideur du futur de ce qui sera la compilation de toutes les connaissances humaines.
C'est simplement inapproprié.
Mais il y a un besoin pour une petite dose de monarchie,
une certaine quantité de -- parfois nous avons à prendre une décision,
et nous ne voulons pas être alourdis et ralentis
par un processus de décision formel.
Un exemple du pourquoi cela c'est fait comme ça --
et de combien cela est important,
nous avons récemment vécu une situation dans laquelle un site néo-Nazi a découvert Wikipedia,
et ils ont dit : "Oh, c'est horrible, ce site est une conspiration juive
et nous allons faire en sorte que certains articles que nous n'aimons pas disparaissent.
Il existe un système de vote, donc nous allons envoyer --
Nous avons 40 000 membres and nous allons les envoyer là-dessus
et ils vont tous voter et faire supprimer ces pages."
En fait ils ont réussi à avoir 18 personnes
Ceci est un exemple de mathématiques Néo-Nazi.
Ils pensent toujours qu'ils ont 40 000 membres alors qu'ils en ont 18.
Mais ils ont réussi à faire en sorte que 18 personnes viennent voter de façon complètement absurde
pour supprimer un article parfaitement valide.
Bien sûr, le vote s'est terminé à 85 voix contre 18,
donc ce n'était pas un réel danger pour notre procédé démocratique.
D'un autre côté, les gens disent :"Mais qu'allons-nous faire ?
Je veux dire, cela pourrait arriver, que ce passerait-il si certains groupes arrivent à s'organiser
nous rejoignent et demande le droit de vote ?"
Et jai dit : "Et bien, tant pis, nous changerons juste les règles."
C'est mon travail dans la communauté : de dire que nous n'autoriserons pas notre ouverture d'esprit
et notre liberté pour plomber la qualité du contenu.
Et aussi longtemps que les gens me feront confiance dans mon rôle,
et bien c'est une place valide pour moi.
Bien sûr, à cause de la licence libre, si je fais du mauvais boulot,
les volontaires sont plus que contents de partir.
Je ne peux dire à personne ce qu'il a à faire.
Donc la conclusion ici est que pour comprendre comment marche Wikipedia,
il est important de comprendre que notre modèle Wiki est notre façon de travailler,
mais nous ne sommes pas des anarchistes fanatiques du web. En fait, notre --
nous sommes très flexible à propos de la méthodologie sociale,
parce que c'est ultimement la passion de la communauté est pour la qualité du travail.
et pas nécessairement pour le procédé que nous utilisons pour le générer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Ben Sauders : Oui, bonjour, Ben Saunders.
Jimmy, vous avez mentionné que l'impartialité est une clef du succès de Wikipedia.
Cela me fait penser aux livres de classe
qui sont utilisés pour éduquer nos enfants sont biaisés de manière inhérente.
Vous-êtes vous rendu compte que Wikipedia est utilisé par des professeurs,
et comment vous pensez que Wikipedia va changer l'éducation ?
Jimmy Wales : Oui, beaucoup de professeurs commencent à utiliser Wikipedia. Une autre --
il y a une ligne historique médiatique sur Wikipedia, et je pense qu'elle est fausse.
Elle se construit sur la chronologie des blogueurs contre les journaux.
Et la chronologie est, il y a cette chose folle, Wikipedia,
mais les académiciens le déteste et les professeurs le déteste. Et on a découvert que ceci était faux.
La dernière fois que j'ai reçu un courriel d'un journaliste disant,
"Pourquoi les universitaires détestent Wikipédia ?"
Je l'ai envoyé de mon courriel d'Harvard
car j'avais été récemment considéré comme collègue là-bas.
Et j'ai dit, "Et bien, ils ne le détestent pas tous."
Mais je pense qu'il y aura des énormes impacts.
Et nous avons actuellement un projet
dont je suis personnellement très excité,
qui est le projet de livres Wiki,
qui est un effort pour créer des livres de classes dans toutes les langues.
Et c'est un projet bien plus gros;
Cela va prendre 20 ans ou a peu près pour qu'il murisse.
Mais une partie de tout ça est pour remplir notre mission
de donner une encyclopédie à toutes les personnes de cette planète.
Nous ne voulons pas dire que nous allons les spammers avec des Cd type AOL.
Nous voulons dire que nous allons leur donner un outil dont ils peuvent se servir.
Et pour un grand nombre de gens dans le monde,
si je vous donne une encyclopédie qui est écrite à un niveau universitaire,
cela ne sert à rien
sans un hébergement complet de matériel littéraire
pour vous amener jusqu'au point ou vous pourriez effectivement vous en servir.
Et le projet de livres Wiki est une avancée pour faire ça.
Je pense que nous allons vraiment voir un énorme --
cela peut même ne pas venir de nous,
tous les types d'innovations possibles sont en cours.
Mais les livres de cours gratuits sont le prochain gros tournant de l'éducation.